the national security law does not  provide legal or judicial safeguards in  such cases I'm also concerned about the  potential reach of the extraterritorial  provisions so I have consulted with Home  Secretary the Justice Secretary and the  Attorney General and the government has  decided to suspend the extradition  treaty immediately and indefinitely she  also tell the house that we would not  consider reactivating those Arrangements  unless and until there are clear and  robust safeguards which are able to  prevent extradition from the UK being  misused under the new national security  legislation  you